let's go next to our caller from the 203
area code we're trying again I guess
with Connecticut maybe we'll have better
luck this time who's there from 203 hey
it's Ali from Connecticut hey Ollie
what's going on hey this one's just
light hearted I was just wondering about
your how-to videos okay
wondering if you get annoyed when people
like goof on them or would you rather
like hide them no no I was 20 years old
I produced a bunch of how-to videos I
starred in some of them everything from
dog training to basketball to I don't
even remember what else I was like the
recipient of a massage and a massage I
don't care it's fine I was 20 years old
I was making more money doing those
videos than any of my 20 year old
friends were making at the time and it
was the start of getting into
audio-visual production and it's it's
funny I don't mind it at all would you
uh would you like do any more as like a
goof I mean listen maybe as a goof but
it's I'm pretty busy right now I don't
know that I'm looking to do
instructional videos but sure if the
right situation presented itself I'd be
in an instructional video again why not
alright last question to a short are you
gonna be at the Boston Street pride
parade oh when is it happening it has it
even been approved I thought it got
blocked or something yeah I think it's
scheduled for the 31st at this month
oh no wait oh I may go and check it out
then and interview some people that that
might actually be interesting I didn't
realize that all right thank you okay
I'll leave from CT appreciate it thanks
for the call